moments ago the Navy announced that
divers found remains in sealed
compartments on the US destroyer that
hit an oil tanker early yesterday now
search and rescue crews have been
searching for ten sailors missing since
the incident involving the USS John s
McCain the collision near Singapore is
the second involving a u.s. warship this
summer and now the US Navy is
temporarily suspending all ship
operations worldwide Ben Tracy is
tracking developments from Beijing Ben
good morning good morning so the Navy is
taking what it's calling an operational
pause what they want to do is give their
ship commanders the chance to work with
their crews on basic seamanship and
teamwork after several incidents here in
the Pacific have called into question
the level of training on u.s. Navy ships
a gaping hole in this eye of another US
warship could be a sign of a bigger
problem in the Pacific the USS John S
McCain suffered extensive damage when it
collided Monday with an oil and chemical
tanker while making a routine port visit
in Singapore Navy officials have not
confirmed an initial investigation that
points to a possible loss of steering
but say their review will consider all
possibilities including sabotage or a
cyberattack we need to get to the bottom
of this so let's get to it in a video
posted online the Chief of Naval
Operations called for all US Navy ships
worldwide to halt operations and review
basic training that directed a more
comprehensive review to ensure that we
get at the contributing factors the root
causes of these incidents just two
months ago another ship from the seventh
fleet the USS Fitzgerald collided with a
merchant ship off the coast of Japan
seven Navy sailors died on Friday the
Fitzgeralds captain commander Bryce
Benson was relieved of his duties and
several other sailors were punished a
sign that mistakes were made on the US
warship it does show that there's still
some kind of systemic issue on the deck
of whether or not there are people that
are qualified whether they're certified
and whether or not they are they are
using all of the things at their
disposal to make sure
this doesn't happen again there have now
been four incidents this year involving
ships from the seventh Fleet in May a
guided missile cruiser collided with a
South Korean fishing vessel and in
January another Cruiser ran aground in
Tokyo Bay I think every commander will
look at their specific units evaluate
the culture evaluate the climate and
make changes in order to make that unit
better China is now taking advantage of
these incidents with these US Navy ships
in editorial today in the state-run
China Daily said very bluntly that the
u.s. Navy is becoming a dangerous
obstacle in Asian waters and posing a
threat to navigation now part of the
reason China is saying this is because
it opposes u.s. Navy warships sailing
through disputed waters that China
claims as its own bill been traced in
Beijing thank you